on débat autour de ces mesures pour
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat avec sandra
hoibian bonjour et bienvenue vous êtes
directrice du pôle société du crédoc
eric delannoy bonsoir bienvenue à tous
avouent aussi économiste président du
cabinet de conseil
tenzing raphaël legendre bonsoir de
saint jouin hills économique à l'opinion
et matthieu croissandeau et reste à mes
côtés est toujours éditorialiste
politique ça n'a pas changé depuis de
l'émission je commence avec vous grâce à
elle parce que en écoutant olivier à
grégoire dans le reportage nous annoncer
qu'une loi allait être adopté en conseil
des ministres avant l'iss l'atv damman
politiquement on voit bien on voit bien
l'intérêt vous dit non ce ne sera pas
possible oui ça va être effectivement
très compliqué contrairement à ce qu'a
dit la nouvelle porte parole du
gouvernement dans la mesure où un le
texte est loin d'être prêt d'abord parce
que ça fait des semaines qu'il n'y a
plus d'un vitrage politique autour des
différentes mesures que c'était que ces
deux textes en réalité qu'il y aura un
texte administratif et une loi de
finances rectificative
dans une loi de finances rectificative
on doit présenter les révisions des
prévisions de croissance de déficit et
de dette pour l'année à venir pour cela
il faut les présenter au conseil
finances publiques rattaché à la cour
des comptes qui n'a pas été saisi un
texte de loi en présente en conseil
d'état avant de le passer en conseil des
ministres ce n'est pas le cas non plus
six s'étaient présentés avant les
législatives il resterait de conseil des
ministres donc c'est très compliqué de
le de le faire et dans les ministères on
s'inquiétait un petit peu aujourd'hui de
savoir comment ça allait se passer parce
qu'a priori ce n est tout simplement pas
faisable c'était quand même étonnant
d'annoncer une telle ou telle mesure si
c'est pas à si c'est pas tenable ce
sandra hoibian comment vous l'expliquez
ça il faut envoyer des signaux aux
français oui tout à fait il ya une homo
rassurer l'union qui a été assez
spectaculaire ces derniers mois
notamment des prix de l'énergie et donc
le gouvernement multiplie en fait les
signaux pour dire aux français on vous
entend on essaye de faire des gestes
donc à un certain nombre de dispositifs
qui sont mis en place les uns après les
autres pour essayer de gérer cette crise
oui eric delannoy il faut pas laisser le
terrain à jean luc mélenchon opposant en
chef des macros il ya la différence
entre être en campagne qui permet de
dire pas mal de choses et être
gouvernement sur lequel il y a un droit
de réserve qui fait que la pression est
limité et qu'à ce titre là c'est
compliqué de prétendre que l'on pourrait
interpréter des premières mesures comme
étant des moments de campagne alors
qu'il essaie de commencer à gérer le des
problématiques des français donc c'est
vrai que c'est une situation qui est
compliqué temporel mais enfin il a fort
la gérer mais pourquoi l'annoncer à ce
moment là pour donner des signaux je
pense que pour montrer qu'il est
quelqu'un à bord ils dès que ce sera
possible ce qu'est ce qui a été évoqué
quand même enfin j'avais entendu olivier
grégoire on dira que ce qui était
bloquée c'est que le premier texte qui
sera sur la table des de la nouvelle
assemblée sera celui là donc après jeu
je suis pas voilà je peux pas en dire
beaucoup plus mais en même temps s'il
n'avait rien dit sur le sujet alors que
c'est quand même la place évidemment on
peut donner des infos sur le contenu
sans dire on va présenter en conseil la
tête et gabriela talent il ya quinze
jours a dit que ce serait après les
législatives et et non pas avant et
cette période de réserve ministérielle
qui a débuté aujourd'hui même
effectivement impose par une circulaire
de février 2000 22 de ne pas communiquer
sur des actions gouvernementales
jusqu'aux législatives pouvoir faire de
concurrence déloyale aux autres
candidats des autres partis et puis un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont dans
la volonté de faire un texte pardon
c'était aussi de présenter un acte fort
un paquet social un paquet pouvoir
d'achat soir de frapper les esprits et
demande aux français qu'on prenait en
compte leur considération mais dans ce
qu est ce qu a commencé à sortir de ce
qui peut ce que pourrait contenir ce
texte il ya tout un nombre de mesures
qui pourraient être prolongées et on
parle de la prolongation du bouclier et
tarifaires alors je prends le soin de
contrôler je pense mais je ne sais pas
s'il faut en passer par une loi pour
prolonger le système de bouclier
tarifaire il ya la prolongation
peut-être de la ristourne carburant
faut-il en passer par une nouvelle loi
s'il s'agit de la prolonger de quelques
mois il ya le fameux chèque alimentation
alors ça sans doute faut-il une parce
que depuis le temps qu'on nous promet ce
chèque alimentation c'est pas juste une
réponse
spontanée à la crise qu'on connaît du
pouvoir d'achat parce que c'est quelque
chose qui était dans les tuyaux déjà
depuis depuis très longtemps mais voilà
il ya quand même des dispositifs qui ne
qui étaient rassemblés sans doute dans
cette fois pour la garnir et montrer
qu'on veut frapper un grand coup sur le
pouvoir d'achat mais qui ne nécessite
peut-être pas de passer devant devant
des législateurs il ya une contrainte
législative qui est que les 4 milliards
d'euros qu'on a mis en trois mois pour
lutter contre la hausse des carburants
notamment ont été pris par décret
d'avancé c'est à dire qu'on a fait sur
d'autres budgets pour pouvoir payer
notamment le chèque carburant et tout
décret d'avancé doit être inscrit dans
une loi de finances au bout de quelques
mois et donc le calendrier impose une
loi de finances pour valider ces décrets
d'abord alors je voudrais qu'on dise un
mot delà de la consommation des
françaises sandra hoibian quelles sont
les conséquences de deux de ces tensions
très fortes sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
notre consommation sur la consommation
des français à quoi elle ressemble cette
console de crise alors la première des
conséquences et une baisse de la
consommation assez nette
ensuite on a des arbitrages sur les sur
les budgets qui peuvent l'être donc
concrètement par exemple on a moins de
français qui partent en vacances que
qu'auparavant on a neuf mois neuf points
de moins qu'avant la cristiani taire
toutes les débuts j'ai le budget
d'habillement a entendu aussi qui en
diminution depuis une dizaine d'années
mais qui a encore encore diminuer les
dépenses aussi on va faire des
arbitrages sur toutes les dépenses qui
peuvent paraître un petit peu accessoire
donc moi aller chez le coiffeur
l'esthéticienne les frères un petit peu
de d'hygiène beauté tout tout ce qui en
fait j'aimerais brosse à dents jantes
pasqualin et d'hygiène beauté donc tout
ce qu'il va faire partie des dépenses
sur lesquelles on a un petit peu de
marge de manoeuvre puisque évidemment
les dépenses de logement les dépenses
d'énergie ces deux sont des dépenses sur
lesquelles c'est pas possible d'agir en
fait à court terme moins de bio aussi
des plus de produits d'entrée de gamme
c'est justement donc après il ya donc
les postes sur lequel on va jouer puis
après à l'intérieur des postes il ya
effectivement la catégorie des produits
et donc on va aller plutôt vers des
produits de marques distributeurs mes
premiers prix et de marques
distributeurs bio on va également avoir
des stratégies pour limiter les achats
donc par exemple se faire une liste de
courses bien précises pour ne pas sortir
en fait de ce qu'on avait prévu limiter
aussi les noms de deux fois on va aller
dans les magasins parce que là aussi ça
permet de limiter finalement le nombre
d'achats et d'imprévus tout un tas de
stratégie finalement pour acheter malin
donc l'achat d'occasion sur internet
qu'on connaît dès maintenant depuis
depuis assez longtemps et la seconde
maintenant on parlait dans le feu la
séquence pleine on a encore de beaux
jours devant elle on va on va est
évoquée maintenant chapitre sur les
leviers possibles ce que le gouvernement
propose mesures ciblées ou pas et puis
peut-être aussi ce que réclament
certains syndicats est ce que les
entreprises peuvent faire peuvent-elles
notamment augmenter les salaires c'est
ce que leur demande laurent berger le
secrétaire général de la cfdt on écoute
la solution c'est d'abord d'augmenter
les salaires notamment de tous ceux qui
ont des bas salaires aujourd'hui il faut
compter tous les pauvres en fait toutes
les greer qui sont en dessous du smic
toutes les grilles sont en dessous du
rejet un an il n'y a pas ou nous ce
qu'on propose au gouvernement ce qu'on a
dit on a écrit d une carte pétition qui
circule sur ce sujet là et d'autres
auprès d'eux pour leur direction du
président c'est toutes les branches qui
ont dénudé minimum en dessous du smic
aujourd'hui ses 144 branche sur 171 de
plus de 5000 salariés commençons tout de
suite elles ont trois mois pour négocier
une revalorisation de leur grille de
tout leur grille de classification et
notamment le bac gris sinon il ya une
conditionnalité des aides publiques
elles peuvent pas percevoir l'ensemble
de l'année
voilà je vous étiez en train de me dire
vous êtes directrice général du credoc
donc pardon je n'avais pas la bonne
information c'est rectifier et je m'en
excuse encore une fois je voudrais voir
eric delannoy cette demande de
du secrétaire général de la cfdt de
laurent berger est ce qu'elle est
légitime augmenter les salaires alors
augmenter les plus bas salaires je
trouve que oui c'est à dire qu'en gros
il faut quand même bien comprendre
pourquoi cette inflation est aussi forte
et aussi puissante à court terme elle
est puissante parce qu'il ya une
conjonction de deux phénomènes une
hausse de la demande qui est lié à la
sortie de crise et au plan de relance
dont qui provoque un choc de demande
jusqu'à ce que l'inflation commence à
rogner un peu et une baisse de l'offre
qui est lié ou de problèmes de supply
chain and équipements et aux prix sous
jacents de la production qui fait que
les prix augmentent les prix de l'offre
augmente donc ça crée un décalage qui se
cumulent et on voit bien que si on met
une augmentation générale des salaires
pour d'augmenter encore la demande ce
décalage on va l'amplifier et donc en
fait on va augmenter l'inflation c'est
ça qui va se passer c'est la raison pour
laquelle la seule chose qui semble
importante en termes économiques après
il ya la théorie économique puis la
politique qui est raisonnable de faire
c'est effectivement non pas de soutenir
comme l'a dit bruno le maire le pouvoir
d'achat des français mais de soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat des populations les plus
modestes tant que des mesures ciblées on
a ciblé et ce à des mesures ciblées il y
en a plein et d'ailleurs c'est un peu
l'orientation qu'a annoncé olivier
grégoire avec d autres des organisations
qui sont très liés à des revalorisations
sur les salaires les plus bas par
rapport à la problématique de
redistribution par rapport à la prime
macron parce que on en viendra peut-être
tout à l'heure mais quand on augmente
les bassins s'appelait la prime patron
un pardon parce que c'est bien les gars
devant qui la verse la prime acronymes
et entreprises on va peut-être en
reparler mais il ya un effet majeur dans
l'augmentation des bas salaires c'est un
écrasement d des échelles de salaire qui
provoque en fait des phénomènes un peu
un peu pénible au niveau de la gestion
d'entreprise en revanche la prime macron
c'est chacun le fait à sa mesure et
c'est défiscaliser désocialisés
l'appel qui est fait c'est qu' un
partage en fait de l'effort entre l'état
et les entreprises il faut quand même
savoir et feu noter il faut rappeler que
le taux de marge des entreprise n'a
jamais été aussi élevé depuis 40 ans par
rapport à toutes les mesures car existe
ça c'est une information importante
effectivement raphaël legendre pas ce
que ça veut dire qu'il ya donc beaucoup
je dis pas tout temps mais beaucoup
d'entreprises qui pourraient augmenter
les salaires et qu'elles ne l'ont pas
être pas suffisamment fait depuis qu une
décennie alors on a une décennie de
stagnation du pouvoir d'achat suite à la
crise financière de 2008 et la crise de
la zone euro ça c'est très clair pas de
croissance très peu d'augmentation des
salaires très peu d'inflation aussi à
l'époque le monde a changé on a une
inflation de 5 % en france on a déjà eu
des négociations collectives au sein des
entreprises qui ont augmenté globalement
les salaires entre 3 et 3 et demi pour
cent mais on sent bien que un deuxième
tour arrivent alors les entreprises
c'est vrai on pour l'instant échappé à
la facture de la hausse de l'inflation
hors mis sur les produits intrants
effectivement sur ce choc de l'offre qui
fait que certaines pièces sont plus
chères plus rares donc plus cher à
acheter mais le choc d'inflation était
pour les 2/3 amortie par l'état par de
la dette c'est tout le paquet pouvoir
d'achat c'est le bouclier tarifaire sur
le gaz l'énergie l'électricité le
pétrole un tiers par les ménages et
c'est vrai que les entreprises pour
l'instant sont plutôt passer au travers
de la facture d'où le maintien
d'ailleurs des embauches au premier
trimestre alors que la croissance a
stoppé nette croissance zéro au premier
trimestre je le je le rappelle mais les
perspectives d'embauché qui était plutôt
intéressant à redon je vous interromps
parce qu'il ya quelque chose que j'ai un
peu de mal à comprendre dit elle sont
passées au travers mais il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ont besoin ça elles
ont toutes besoin d'énergie de pétrole
pour faire rouler les lire les flottes
automobiles achètent des matières
premières bien sûr mais à lui 2 elif ici
au semi conducteurs etc l'état sur
notamment le paquet énergie les
industries par exemple l'énergie bord
très fortement énergivores ont un plan
dédié pour les aider à passer cette
bosse difficile de l'inflation sur un
prix pour l'instant c'est aussi de
l'énergie qui me prend en charge c'est
plutôt les tares et deux tiers et les
ménages pour un tiers mais on voit que
les entreprises vont devoir prendre une
partie de cette hausse des prix en
remettant effectivement un peu d'eau de
salaires d'ici la fin de l'année et puis
il ya un autre il ya un autre élément
sandra hoibian c'est le dégel du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires ça c'est pas
c'est pas totalement neutre ce qui a été
annoncé en général ça il ya un petit
effet boule de neige c'est ça oui c'est
quand même une part importante en fait
il ya un salarié sur cinq qui
travaillent dans la fonction publique
c'est quand même une grosse masse aussi
de personnes et puis le point n'avait
pas bougé depuis 2010 est donc ça fait
quand même aussi un certain temps donc
c'est un message qui est envoyé en
espérant que les entreprises vont suivre
qu'il va y avoir un effet puisque les
marchés de l'emploi ils n'ont pas une
forme de porosité et puis c'est aussi un
message politique par rapport aux
fonctionnaires il ya quand même beaucoup
de débats autour des salaires des
enseignants de la fonction publique des
gens qui étaient en première ligne donc
c'est aussi un message qui est envoyé
politiquement probablement oui avec une
réunion en cette fin d'après midi à
bercy autour de 2 bruno le maire tient
je vous propose là la réaction du
président de la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises françois
à cela il rappelle que beaucoup
d'entreprises ont fait des augmentations
individuelles on va lire cette citation
est que grosso modo y aura pas de hausse
de salaire
uniforme qu'est-ce-qui ce qu'est ce qui
se joue ce soir à bercy raphaël legendre
un partage 2 une pression
gouvernementale ça on a bien vu le
l'image politique ça va représenter mais
un partage des tâches ou des poids c'est
d'abord et avant tout le retour de bruno
le maire sur la scène à bercy en tant
que super ministre qui a gardé tous ses
pouvoirs et un merci unis c'est une
vraie victoire de bruno le maire dans ce
remaniement c'est donc une mise en scène
on se remet au travail je convoque tout
le monde et on va discuter des sujets et
des grands débats économiques qui nous
attendent qui sont devant nous c'est un
message et un appel aux entreprises
effectivement à prendre leur part dans
cette lutte contre la vie chère avec
aussi en tête l'idée qu'il faut éviter
la fameuse boucle prix salaires que
craint énormément bercy ce sens les
rivales à notre les prix augmentent du
coup les salaires augmentent ce qui fait
augmenter les prix de vente des
entreprises aussi et on nourrit
l'inflation comme ça sans vraiment
savoir comment remettre le dentifrice
dans le tube à la sortie donc bercé
alors pour les français qui nous
écoutent sur toujours des difficultés le
salaire augmenté depuis trois ans et
demi trois et demi pour cent
d'augmentation ça reste inférieur aux 5
% d'inflation mais ce sont quand même
des des augmentations sensibles mais
surtout il ya 1,9 million d'entreprises
en france est ce qui explique françois
st très bien c'est qu'il ya un grille 9
millions d'histoires différentes toutes
les entreprises pas de mesure je ne sont
pas dans le même état financier et donc
pas les moyens de faire une mesure
générale et ce n'est pas ce que demande
un bercy encore une fois c'est
simplement pour les secteurs et les
entreprises qui le peuvent qu'elle fasse
un effort et puis peut-être un autre
élément qu'il faut on fait de la
pédagogie dans ce dans cette émission
eric delannoy il ya déjà eu des hausses
de salaires par branche d'activité est
en fête
la nouvelle hausse du smic devrait
enclencher de nouvelles négociations
c'est ce qui se passe le tfc s'est
effectivement parce que la hausse du
smic a des répercussions sur l'ensemble
de l'échelle des salaires et donc tout
le sujet en général on estime que la
hausse du smic a un impact direct sur
les sur les salaires qui sont à peu près
1,5 le smic donc par des effets de
compensation par des effets de parce que
tout simplement quelqu'un qui dépasse
une personne qui a un virus 5% du smic
parce qu'il vient d'être augmentée bah
finalement le plus on peut le remplacer
et ses stars donc il ya des effets de de
compensation potentiel donc ça nécessite
effectivement de revoir cette échelle de
salaire sans qu'on soit dans une boucle
prix salaires et ont un goût une
augmentation générale c'est pour ça que
la prime mâcon est intelligente parce
que elle se fait elle se fait dans la
capacité de l'entreprise de pouvoir le
faire or quand on fait une augmentation
générale des salaires voire une
augmentation sur les bas salaires mais
mais en allant assez haut un non
seulement ça coûte à l'état parce que je
vous rappelle qu'il ya des exonérations
de charges sociales jusqu'à tout est
quasiment 2,5 smic aujourd'hui et qui à
ce titre là quand on augmente les bas
salaires bas on augmente la surface de
pub population qui qui est exonérée de
charges donc les la dame en plus ça
coûte à l'état donc il faut trouver des
mécanismes dans lequel l'état investit
fin surinvesti peu j'ai envie de dire ça
et par ailleurs l'entreprise ne va pas
complètement
bouger à sa hiérarchie des salaires et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il valoir
ses négociations pour faire en sorte de
augmenté sans trop augmenter et sans
trop toucher cette hiérarchie dernier
aspect il ya quand même un point aussi
qu'il faut qui conquit qui milite en
plus pour ne pas aller vers 7h générale
des salaires c'est que dans les salariés
il ya des cadres il ya des agents de
maîtrise il ya des gens qui gagnent bien
leur vie et c'est gentil millions d
emplois épargnés depuis
fortement mais on est à 175 milliards de
d'euros 675 milliard on estime que c'est
à peu près 25 à 35 % de la population
qu'il a épargnée jusqu'à quasiment dix
mille euros par foyer et que donc à un
moment enfin ça plus personne n'en parle
enfin et alors pour les inciter à
consommer il faut il faut quoi des
mesures mais faut les inciter
parce que le climat général n'est pas
très rassurant on va dire ça donc ça
peut inciter à rester prudent et ne pas
toucher à son départ sonnait enfin la
consommation c'est aux alentours de 1200
milliards par an c'est 4% sur un an
complet on n'y est pas encore ces 50
milliards 175 milliards pour ceux qui
ont les outils ont cette épargne la
salle et voir venir ce que je dire par
là c'est que c'est vraiment de l'
épargne supplémentaire on dit au
qu'ovide inquiets lit de la non
consommation et qu'à ce titre là il faut
surtout pas leur donner de l'argent plus
à ces gens là ils n'en n'ont pas besoin
alors c'est peut-être choquant à dire
c'est politiquement incorrect de le dire
c'est pour ça que il faut vraiment
militer pour la frange la population qui
a des revenus modestes qui elle souffre
et on en revient aux mesures ciblées
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure sandra
hoibian c'est ce qui est intéressant
c'est l'aspect psychologique dans dans
la capacité à faire a redonné de la de
la fluidité à cette épargne à la
remettre finalement dans le circuit de
l'économie oui psychologique est aussi
finalement ce sont des arbitrages
sociaux qu'est ce qu'on décide de quels
sont les richesses qu'on décide de
répartir vers qui l'a tout à l'heure on
parlait de la paix un peu la prime a
conquis été défiscalisée ça signifie que
finalement concrètement les gens
n'auront pas ces montants là dans leur
épargne au départ c'était compenser et
maintenant ça l'est plus donc il ya
aussi une question de finalement quelles
sont les ressources qu'on mais qu'on met
au pot commun et là globalement la
plupart des êtres qui ont été mises en
place elles sont ciblées sur les plus
modestes alors ça peut paraître assez
logique puisqu'on se dit baye a de plus
en plus de besoins sociaux le
vieillissement la dépendance qui on n'a
pas envie d'augmenter les impôts donc il
faut bien faire quelque chose pour vous
retrouver pour résoudre l'équation le
problème de ces mesures c'est que à
court terme elles sont très positifs
parce qu'elles vont rassurer les ménages
elles vont les sécuriser à long terme
elle crée un sentiment d'injustice
permanence c'est à dire que chacun va se
demander est ce que moi j'ai vraiment eu
toutes les aides ce que j'ai eu les
mêmes aides que les autres et du coup on
a aussi un consentement à l'impôt un
regard sur la protection sociale qui et
distanciée notamment chez les classes
moyennes donc je serai un petit peu plus
réservé sur l'idée de réserver toutes
les aides aux plus modestes même si
évidemment ils en ont plus besoin et ça
paraît logique mais il ya aussi une
question finalement démocratique de
comment est ce qu'on décide vers qui on
va on va verser des aides et notamment
cette question des classes moyennes
alors je vous propose de comparer un peu
maintenant la situation de la france à
celle de nos voisins européens grâce à
steve jours d'un rebond soit
valve on en est où par rapport à aux
autres pays d'europe on va service il ya
une exception française thomas en avril
on va voir je voudrais plein de chiffres
en avril l'inflation de la zone euro a
atteint 7,4 pour cent sur un an ce un
niveau qui est bien supérieur à
l'objectif des 2% théoriquement fixé par
la banque centrale européenne et quand
on regarde dans le détail on se rend
compte et bien que la france s'en tire
plutôt est bien très bien par rapport
aux autres pays de la zone euro
l'inflation en france estimé à 4 8% par
l'insee au mois d'avril ça fait de nous
et bien l'un des pays où l'inflation est
la plus faible de toute la zone euro au
18e pays sur dix neuf c'est pas mal de
vent nous retrouve l'estonie les pays
bas la grèce l'espagne l'allemagne ou
encore l'italie avec 6 6% samedi bruno
le maire s'est félicité de cette
relative bonne performance française
écoutez le une inflation à près de 5%
c'est toujours trop
et l'inflation est évidemment notre
premier défi politique et économique
mais je rappelle que cette inflation
elle est à près de 8% en allemagne
près de 9% en espagne et plus de 11 %
aux pays-bas
grâce aux mesures qui ont été voulus par
le président la république le taux
d'inflation en france est le plus faible
de la zone euro est ce vraiment grâce
aux mesures voulues par emmanuel macron
que la france s'en sort mieux voilà
c'est un petit peu plus complexe plus
sain selon les échos miss des
économistes la principale peut-être plus
important des raisons tient à notre mix
énergétique le conflit on écrème a fait
exploser les prix des énergies mais le
nucléaire nous a permis en quelque sorte
de limiter la casse nucléaire on le
rappelle ça représente environ 70 % de
notre production d'électricité c'est
beaucoup ça nous permet d'être moins
exposés au vent des marchés que d'autres
pays en matière d'énergie à titre de
comparaison thomas l'allemagne est plus
dépendante au gaz naturel et au charbon
le gaz c'est 27 % la consommation
globale allemande le charbon c'est 18% 2
énergie qui ont flambé à l'occasion de
cette guerre en ukraine et puis il faut
quand même citer les mesures qui ont été
adoptées prises par le gouvernement pour
limiter la flambée des prix il ya le
bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz et
l'électricité il a été mis en place en
fin à la fin de l'année dernière il a
été prolongé jusqu'au mois de juin et
puis à la prime de 18 centimes sur le
carburant qu'on attend maintenant bien
de voir à quoi ressemblera très
précisément ce projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat il sera présenté avant le
premier tour des élections législatives
merci steve jour d'impôt pour toutes ces
explications a fait le gendre en
entendant tout ça je me dis qu'on a une
économie qui est quand même de plus en
plus administrer ce n'est pas très
nouveau mais encore plus quoi il ya
d'ailleurs quelques libéraux qui
s'arrache les cheveux mais avec une
forme de dirigisme qui n'arrête pas de
progresser alors peut-être que c'est dû
aussi au score de la france insoumise et
maintenant la grande coalition de gauche
du ps qui est un vrai danger pour les
législatives pour la majorité mais dans
ce paquet pouvoir d'achat il ya des
idées qui circulent qui n'ont pas encore
été officialisée mais comme une super
taxe sur les profits des énergéticiens
qui pue lui aussi au niveau européen pas
qu'en france mais on en parle en france
vous avez le
suppléa profit d'accords de rente à vie
temporaire qui s'est installée sur les
le producteur d'électricité notamment
donc certains pays l'italie la
grande-bretagne et autres ont décidé de
taxer ces supers profits temporairement
vous avez l'idée d'un gel des loyers qui
circule beaucoup en ce moment elisabeth
bornes dans le journal du dimanche a
plus tôt balayé l'idée en mais bruno le
maire lui y est plutôt favorable on en
discute en ce moment donc on voit qu'il
ya effectivement une place de l'état de
plus en plus grande et alors c'est vrai
que on peut se féliciter qu'en france
l'inflation ne soit qu'à 5% finalement
c'est pas totalement délirant c'est le
double dans d'autres pays mais si cette
inflation aussi faible on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est parce que l'état a pris
des deux tiers du coût de cette
inflation mais attention c'est de la
dette supplémentaire le bouclier
tarifaire sur l'énergie ces 26 milliards
d'euros pour l'instant peut être appelée
à augmenter dans l'est dans les mois qui
viennent et si le consommateur est
préservé pour l'instant le contribuable
lui paiera la facture dans un deuxième
temps il en être quand même très
conscient alors cela un chiffre sur
cette dette française 2008 113 milliards
d'euros 113 % du produit intérieur brut
annuel de la france est ce que c'est une
bombe à retardement eric delannoy c'est
une bombe à retardement à moyen terme
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut
comprendre comment se constitue une
dette une dette sur les 2600 milliards
de d'euros c'est une dette qui se
constitue par j'annule fin j'annule je
rembourse ses dettes que j'ai fait il ya
dix ans il y avait 15 ans il ya vingt
ans il ya deux ans il ya un an et je
reconstitue mon stock de dette en en
achetant de la nouvelle ce qu'on appelle
leur releveur de la dette d'accord ça
veut dire que le panier de la dette
change chaque année là c'est dire que la
structure moyenne de la dette change
chaque année pour donner un exemple à
l'époque où l'été les taux étaient
importants 1996 par exemple le taux
moyen de ce panier de dette était de 6
et demi pour cent six et demi pour cent
allez donc une charge la dette cessé de
nous pour cent de cet encours là qu'ils
étaient très forts ce taux moyen avec la
chute des taux donc la room allemand de
la dette avec de la dette toujours plus
bas est tombé à 1,25 en 2020 ce qui
compte est la paix
dehors les taux mais ça je joue en
phénomène inverse les taux sont en train
de me remonter il ya un os à thé donc
est un indice de référence à 10 ans qui
valait 0 1% en début d'année qui est
maintenant à 1,6 pour cent dans les
mondes les taux remonter
significativement
donc ça veut dire que la nouvelle dette
qu'on va se constituer et beaucoup plus
cher que celle qu'on avait dans le
panier donc effectivement le taux global
va augmenter sauf qu'il ya une inertie
énorme de cette dette l'agent cela veut
dire qu'on est tranquille pour combien
de temps on est tranquille on s'arrose
c'est un débat qu'on avait avec raphaël
tout à l'heure on est tranquille en gros
pour malheureusement c'est un chiffre
magique mais en gros pour cinq ans donc
bizarrement donc les effets vont
commencer à se voir dans deux ans c'est
à dire qu'en gros quand vous prenez un
pointe plus de pivot ça impacte et 10%
de la dette d'accor et en gros on estime
alors on peut ne pas être d'accord sur
certaines estimations qui ont fait mais
que à horizon cinq à dix ans et une
augmentation de la charge de la dette si
les cils et augmente d'un point de 40 à
50 milliards mathieu et moi je suis
frappé de voir comment ce thème de la
dette qui était structurants dans le
débat public français a complètement
disparu sas a permis à des gens de
j'allais dire de faire un fond de
commerce politique en tout cas d'exister
politiquement pour les françois bayrou
par exemple qui s'était fait l'ardent
défenseur de l'ardent défenseur je les
dires de la lutte contre la dette prenez
françois fillon qui s'était fait un
programme massif avant je parle d'un
vent tous ces scandales qui avait fait
un programme de 2 d'orthodoxie
budgétaire absolument
qui agit à dire canon au sens des canons
de l'orthodoxie pour préserver justement
cette dette est aujourd'hui à cause sans
doute de l'effet qu'au vide à cause du
quoi qu'il en coûte partir de ce moment
où ce mot là a été prononcé je pense que
ça fait disparaître cette notion du
débat public et puis à autre chose c'est
que la dette l'argument des gens qui
voulaient lutter contre la dette c'était
précisément ce que raphaël 18 alors
c'est à dire que c'est le contribuable
de demain donc les générations futures
qui vont le petit viking qui vont payer
la dette alors vous me dites que les
générations futures 8 arrangé puisque
huit ans mais globalement mal ce thème
deux générations futures été
complètement mis sur un autre dossier
qui évidemment celui du climat et donc
on pense aux générations futures pour le
climat pas du tout pour la dette qui a
complètement disparu des écrans radar
raphaël
legendre c'est ce cet argent magique là
ça fait des années jaillir des mois mais
non des années qu'on est
drogué à l'argent magique sauf que là le
robinet va se faire mais on le sait déjà
près exactement ça commencer en 2014
quand la banque centrale européenne par
manque d'inflation à l'époque se met à
racheter toutes les dettes de la zone
euro public privé par dizaines de
milliards d'euros pour relancer
justement un peu l'inflation on est dans
une situation complètement inverse
aujourd'hui la mission principale de la
banque centrale européenne c'est le
contrôle des prix le maintien d'une
inflation autour de 2% et donc christine
lagarde a annoncé il ya quelques jours
la fin de ces achats massifs de dette et
notamment de dette publique dès la fin
du mois de juin et des premières hausses
de taux de la banque centrale européenne
à partir du mois de juillet on pourrait
avoir une hausse de 0 75 points de base
0 75% d'ici la fin de l'année une hausse
de 1% ces deux milliards de hausse sur
la charge de la dette sur les intérêts
qu'on paye chaque année au bout d'un an
et 40 milliards comme le disait tout à
l'heure au bout de dix ans ça c'est le
premier effet kiss cool qui va nous
coûter cher le deuxième c'est
l'inflation et ça on le paye tout de
suite 10 % de la dette française est
indexé sur l'inflation l'inflation
augmenté de 5 % la facture sera au bas
mot 2 8 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dès cette année a ajouté
l'osdh et on sera probablement a déjà
une hausse du coût de 10 milliards nous
ne sommes que la première année des huit
années de rowling de la dette donc c'est
une certitude le point de la dette va
augmenter dans les prochaines années et
donc attention attention aux dépenses
mais ça a quand même sandra hoibian à
un impact évident sur la politique des
manuels macron même si vous nous dites
bon bah finalement les effets seront
peut-être à la fin de son second
quinquennat mais il a fait de la baisse
des impôts à un marqueur politique
est-ce que c'est tenable tout simplement
en fait on dit au crédoc qu'on est un
peu dans une gestion de la paire ma
crise c'est à dire qu'on a une crise qui
est remplacée par une autre donc
l'opinion les pouvoirs publics sont pris
dans cette espèce de tourbillon de crise
et donc on va répondre à chaque fois et
finalement on a un petit peu perdues
aussi la capacité à ne pas voir les
événements comme des crises mais à les
restituer dans le temps long donc on
pourrait se dire l'inflation par exemple
là c'est très très fort mais si on se
replace un peu dans le temps long on a
eu des taux d'inflation beaucoup plus
élevé dans les années 80 la même manière
sur la pandémie a évidemment eu beaucoup
de morts et ça a bouleversé les
économies occidentales mais il faut se
rappeler qu'il ya eu deux épidémies en
fait en france on peut penser à la
grippe de 68 et tout le monde l'a oublié
en fait donc il ya aussi probablement
dans la façon dont on notre société
aujourd'hui vie un regard qui est porté
sur les événements qui nous pousse à
nous focaliser sur le court terme et je
crois que tout à l'heure vous parliez
des enjeux de plus long terme la
jeunesse aujourd'hui nous rappelle qu'
il ya aussi des enjeux de plus long
terme et notamment ses enjeux
écologiques ça va se jouer à bruxelles
delannoy
il est clair que la dimension européenne
c'est une dimension qui nous aide
beaucoup lorsque la bce enfin si au
moins un endroit où il ya une
intégration qui s'est fait de manière
efficace c'est par la banque centrale
européenne qui aujourd'hui est
détentrice de notre politique
aujourd'hui la banque de france n'existe
plus si ce n'est dans sa participation à
la bande annonce entreprennent donc oui
ça va jouer là bas parce que typiquement
c'est eux qui sont les maîtres des clés
autour de l'augmentation des taux mais
c'est très dangereux parce que c'est
pour ça qu'ils aient une espèce
d'attentisme pour le moment augmenter
les taux veut dire baisser d
investissement au risque et de casser
une croissance dont on voit qu'elle est
déjà un petit peu en berne alors qu'on
était reparti suite à la fin du camp
vide donc c'est une équation qui
aujourd'hui est extrêmement compliqué ce
qui explique qu'à des effets d'annoncé
sur le fait qu'on va relever les taux
mais qu'on ne fait pas tout de suite
parce que beaucoup d'économistes
aujourd'hui et j'en fais partie
prétendre que l'inflation que l'on vit
aujourd'hui est une inflation
conjoncturelle et non pas structurelle
que ça va pas durer ça durera alors ça
peut durer longtemps malheureusement
parce que c'est d'autres considérations
qui rentrent en jeu ça durera le temps
du conflit ukrainien est d'accord c'est
lise directement à la ligue arabe a pour
beaucoup et puis bien évidemment avec
toutes les répercussions donc il ya des
effet d'inertie qui joue mais on n'est
pas sur des fondamentaux économiques qui
sont mauvais en fait dans les économies
notamment européennes avec des échanges
qui sont très importants et qui
fonctionne bien par contre on a des
effets conjoncturels les suites du coc
vides et des effets mais les effets de
la guerre sur sur sept qui anime à
l'inflation qui va durer ou bah moi je
lui en serai un peu parce que l'on
disait déjà il ya un an que c'était
conjoncturelle et qu'au printemps 2022
sacré passé on a trois étapes moi je
vois trois choses on a effectivement une
inflation conjoncturel sur les prix de
l'énergie et les produits alimentaires
avec notamment la crise du blé qui
effectivement son passage et on espère
qu'on en sortira le plus rapidement
possible puisque ça dépend notamment la
résolution du conflit ukrainien à moyen
terme vous avez quand même ce choc
d'offre qui ne sera pas
solutionné dans les mois à venir avec
une région ne religieux nalisation de la
mondialisation l'asie se referme sur
elle-même les etats unis font de même et
l'europe va devoir rés industrialiser
son territoire pour être plus autonome
ce qui va pousser les prix à la hausse
bien évidemment on produira plus cher en
europe que ce qu'on importe de la chine
et à long terme ce qui va coûter très
cher c'est la transition
environnementale ou bien sûr la
transition écologique coûtera très cher
produire produire produire vers pardon
coûte beaucoup plus cher que la
production carbonées et ça on y est pour
des décennies jusqu'en 2050 et au delà
donc ces poussées inflationnistes sont
très certainement là pour durer merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est